RICK: How can I help you?
Well, I have a coin here.
It's a portrait coin of
Julius Caesar from the month
before he got assassinated.
RICK: OK.
ILYA: This coin is
really interesting.
RICK: Yeah, this is cool.
Yes.
I think I was actually Caesar
in a different lifetime.
[laughs]
ILYA: I'm coming
into the shop today
because I have a
portrait Julius Caesar
coin that I want to sell.
I believe it's a key piece to
any historical coin collection.
I'm hoping to sell
it for $4,400.
But I absolutely love it,
so I'm not going to take
any lowball offer for it.
RICK: Yeah, this is cool.
I mean, you have
Caesar Dictator.
One of the neat things
is is where it says
Dictator on the front of it--
that's a negative term nowadays.
But back then, it wasn't.
During times of war,
they would assign
a person the title Dictator.
And a Dictator would do what
was necessary to preserve
the Republic.
After Julius Caesar
was assassinated,
there was a real
power vacuum in Rome.
And it wasn't until
Octavius that basically
straightened everything out.
The great thing about this
is it's a 2000-year-old coin
with Caesar's face on it.
And I want it.
So are you looking to sell it?
ILYA: Yeah.
- OK.
How much were you
looking to get out of it?
I want $4,400 please.
RICK: OK.
There's a million variables,
especially with ancient coins.
And quite frankly,
I don't know enough.
I don't know if that's
a good price or not.
Do you mind if I have
someone look at it?
Sure.
Please.
All right.
I'll be right back.
ILYA: Thank you.
I'm really excited that
an expert is coming in
to attest to its authenticity.
RICK: Since the Roman Empire
doesn't exist anymore,
it's not illegal to
fake these coins.
And I have to find out
if this is the real deal.
So I called in Dave.
This is the coin.
DAVID VAGI: OK.
Julius Caesar.
Few names in history
ring with the familiarity
of Julius Caesar.
You know, there's Napoleon.
You know, a few of the
people you can throw in.
His murder inspired Shakespeare.
- Yeah.
DAVID VAGI: I mean, this is
a serious bit of history.
This particular coin was
struck within 30 days prior
to Julius Caesar's murder.
Many historians believe that
the fact that his portrait
appeared on a coin
was one of the things
that led to his murder.
RICK: So is it real?
Do you mind if I take
it out and look at it?
Yeah.
Sure.
Go ahead.
Examine it.
DAVID VAGI: The
strike is perfect.
The style is correct.
Everything is right.
RICK: OK.
DAVID VAGI: It's
perfectly genuine.
All right.
So what do you
think it's worth?
DAVID VAGI: When you
get a coin like this,
there's no shortage of buyers.
When they are in
fantastic condition,
the very best of these have
brought in the neighborhood
of $200,000 each.
RICK: OK.
DAVID VAGI: But there's
a good amount of wear.
It's circulated.
And I think this is worth in
the neighborhood of $1,500.
RICK: Retail?
- Retail.
RICK: OK.
ILYA: To me, it seems
almost ridiculous
that somebody would
sell it that low,
especially when they
knew its history.
DAVID VAGI: Well,
I'm basing it on what
I've seen them sell for
in auctions in Europe
and the United States.
But the decision is yours.
Thanks for coming in, man.
All righty, man.
One last question--
where can I
get these for such low prices?
ILYA: I understand why the
seller is not happy with that.
You know, the fact is these
things are undervalued.
And it's probably best
that he holds onto it
because the bottom line is it's
difficult to replace for less
than its current market value.
RICK: Dave-- he's been in the
coin business his entire life.
And I'm gonna take his opinion.
You know, I'd give you
$1,000 for the coin.
ILYA: Is this a real offer?
Or--
RICK: That's a legitimate offer.
Yeah.
That's not a legitimate offer.
You're just using your position
here trying to buy something
for below its market value.
RICK: The way market value
is determined is when
two people agree on a price.
If you don't like my price,
you don't have to take it.
- How about $4,000?
- No.
There's no money to be made.
I have final offer
for you. $3,500.
And I'll take cash,
100 dollar bills.
I guess we're not
gonna make a deal, man.
Your loss, my friend.
- Thanks for coming in.
- Thank you.
Have a nice one.
The offer of $1,000 is
absolutely ridiculous.
I'm going to hold
onto the coin, and I'm
going to try to
sell it to someone
else that could
actually appreciate
its true historical value.